>>> OXYGEN IS RUNNING OUT, MAYBE
LESS THAN 12 HOURS LEFT.
RACING TO LOCATE THE MISSING SUB
NEAR THE TITANIC HOPING THAT THE
NOISES HEARD OVERNIGHT PROVIDE
SOME DIRECTION.
>> AND WHAT IS IT LIKE TO BE
INSIDE OCEANGATE'S TITAN
SUBMERSIBLE?
WHEN IT LOSES COMMUNICATION WITH
THE SURFACE?
YOU WILL HEAR FROM SOMEONE WHO
EXPERIENCED THAT VERY THING.
>> A POTENTIAL CATASTROPHIC
OUTCOME WAS WAITING TO HAPPEN
ACCORDING TO A FORMER EMPLOYEE
AND AN INDUSTRY WATCHDOG.
WERE SAFETY CONCERNS IGNORED BY
THE SUBMERSIBLE COMPANY?
THOSE STORIES AND MORE RIGHT
HERE ON "CNN NEWS CENTRAL."
♪♪
>>> WE ARE GETTING NEW
INFORMATION IN JUST THE LAST FEW
MINUTES ON THE SEARCH FOR THE
MISSING SUB NEAR THE TITANIC.
THE U.S. COAST GUARD IS
REDIRECTING ITS SEARCH THIS
MORNING AFTER A CANADIAN
MILITARY PLANE PICKED UP
UNDERWATER NOISES.
THERE ARE FIVE PEOPLE ONBOARD
RUNNING OUT OF OXYGEN, RUNNING
OUT OF TIME.
A NEW ROUND OF SHIPS LEFT
NEWFOUNDLAND THIS MORNING TO
JOIN THE SEARCH EFFORTS.
NOW NOISES ARE NOT UNCOMMON IN
THE OPEN OCEAN, BUT RESCUERS
SAID THEY HEARD BANGING SOUNDS
IN 30-MINUTE INTERVALS, REGULAR
SPACES.
AN EXPERT AND FRIEND TOLD US
THAT FACT COULD BE SIGNIFICANT.
>> THE BANGING SOUNDS ARE
INTERESTING BECAUSE KNOWING
NARGEOLET AND HIS EXPERIENCE
WITH SUBMERSIBLES AND HIS
BACKGROUND WITH SUBMARINES THIS
IS EXACTLY HOW HE WOULD TRY TO
INDICATE THAT THEY WERE STILL
ALIVE AND TRY TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THE SURFACE.
YOU WOULD DO SOME BANGING AND DO
IT ON A REGULAR SCHEDULE SO IT
WAS DISTINGUISHABLE FROM THE
BACKGROUND NOISES IN THE OCEAN
ALL OF THE TIME.
>> CNN'S MIGUEL MARQUEZ IS IN
ST. JOHN'S IN NEWFOUNDLAND WHICH
IS THE CLOSEST LAND MASS.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING THIS
MORNING?
>> WELL, WE'RE SEEING -- WE SAW
A LOT OF ACTIVITY HERE OVERNIGHT
AND EARLY THIS MORNING.
COAST GUARD SHIP, A THIRD
CANADIAN COAST GUARD SHIP NOW
HEADED OUT THAT WAY.
IT TAKES, 10, 18 HOURS TO GET TO
THE SITE WHERE THEY'RE
SEARCHING.
THE HORIZON ARCTIC LEFT EARLIER
THIS MORNING AND THIS IS AFTER
THREE U.S. MILITARY PLANES,
C-17s AND VERY BIG CARGO PLANES
FLEW INTO ST. JOHN'S AIRPORTS
AND THAT GEAR WAS PUT ON TO THE
HORIZON
HORIZON ARCTIC AND THAT IS ON
ITS WAY RIGHT NOW.
WITH REGARD TO THE BANGING, THEY
HEARD IT OVER A FOUR-HOUR PERIOD
EVERY HALF HOUR OR SO AND THEY
PUT SONAR BUOYS INTO THE OCEAN.
THEY HEARD OTHER NOISES LATER ON
AND IT WASN'T BANGING, BUT
THEY'RE NOT CLEAR WHAT IT WAS.
THEY MOVED RESOURCES AND THEY
MOVED SHIPS THAT WERE ON THE
SURFACE TO THE AREA WHERE THEY
THOUGHT THE BANGING WAS COMING
FROM.
THEY PUT REMOTE OPERATED
VEHICLES IN THE AREA HOPING TO
FIND THE SUBMERSIBLE, BUT THEY
DID NOT.
SO NOW THEY'RE PUTTING MORE
RESOURCES ON IT AND THEY HAVE
SEVERAL COAST GUARD SHIPS THAT
DO SIDE SONAR THAT MEANS THEY
CAN MAP THE BOTTOM OF THE OCEAN
LOOKING FOR A VISUAL SIGNATURE
OF THE SUBMERSIBLE TO SEE IF
THEY CAN FIND IT IN THAT AREA
WHERE THE BANGING WAS COMING
FROM, BUT IT IS ALL HANDS ON
DECK.
IF THEY ARE ALIVE, THEY HAVE
VERY LITTLE TIME LEFT AND PEOPLE
HERE AND EVERYWHERE ARE JUST
HOPING THAT THIS TERRIFYING
ORDEAL COMES TO A HAPPY ENDING.
JOHN?
>> THEY STILL HAVE HOPE.
THAT'S FOR SURE, BUT WE ARE
WAITING FOR MORE UPDATES AT THIS
POINT FROM THE COAST GUARD AND
OTHER OFFICIALS.
MIGUEL MARQUEZ, KEEP US POSTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KATE?
>> HOLDING OUT HOPE WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING OF JUST HOW RISKY,
HOW DANGEROUS IT IS DOWN THERE
AS EVERYONE KNOWS.
>> THERE'S ONLY A HANDFUL OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE EVER SEEN THE
TITANIC'S WRECKAGE IN PERSON AND
IT IS PART OF A GROWING TREND
KNOWN AS EXTREME TOURISM WHERE
PEOPLE PAY HUGE SUMS OF MONEY TO
PUSH THE TRAVEL, AND IT IS
INHERENTLY DANGEROUS.
CNN HAS LEARNED TWO -- CNN HAS
LEARNED THAT YEARS AGO TWO
EMPLOYEES RAISED SAFETY CONCERNS
ABOUT THE NOW MISSING OCEANGATE
SUBMARINE.
CNN'S TOM FOREMAN HAS MORE ON
THIS AND HE'S JOINING US NOW.
TOM, WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING?
>> HI, KATE.
AS THE HOURS TICK DOWN, THE
QUESTIONS ARE COMING UP MORE AND
MORE ABOUT HOW THIS REACHED THIS
POINT.
SPECIFICALLY, HOW THIS
SUBMERSIBLE WAS DEVELOPED.
YOU MENTIONED THE EMPLOYEES
THERE AND AN INDUSTRY GROUP AND
THERE WAS A LETTER FROM THE NEW
YORK TIMES FROM THEM IN WHICH
THEY SAID WHAT WAS HAPPENING AT
OCEANGATE AND OUR APPREHENSION
THAT THE EXPERIMENTAL APPROACH
AND DEVELOPING THIS CRAFT COULD
RESULT IN NEGATIVE OUTCOME FROM
MINOR TO CATASTROPHIC THAT WOULD
HAVE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES FOR
EVERYONE IN THE INDUSTRY, AND IT
WENT ON TO SAY YOUR MARKETING
MATERIAL ADVERTISES THAT THE
TITAN DESIGN WILL MEET OR EXCEED
THE DMVGL SAFETY STANDARDS AND
THESE ARE STANDARDS DEVELOPED A
LONG TIME AGO FOR THIS TYPE OF
VESSEL AND YET IT DOES NOT
APPEAR THAT OCEANGATE HAS THE
INTENTION OF FOLLOWING YOUR
CLASS RULES AND YOUR
REPRESENTATION IS AT MINIMUM
MISLEADING TO THE PUBLIC AND
LEADS A PROFESSIONAL CODE OF
CONDUCT WE ALL ENDEAVOR TO
UPHOLD.
SIMPLY PUT, KATE.
YEARS AGO THERE WERE PEOPLE IN
THE COMPANY AND OUTSIDE THE
COMPANY SAYING YOUR APPROACH TO
DEVELOPING THIS CRAFT IS TOO
EXPERIMENTAL, TOO OUTSIDE THE
NORMS AND IS NOT BEING SUBMITTED
TO THE STANDARDS THAT WORLDWIDE
MARITIME ORGANIZATIONS EXPECT.
BOTTOM LINE IS, A VEHICLE LIKE
THIS, ENGINEERS SHOULD SAY
SHOULD BE TESTED TO TWO, THREE,
FOUR, FIVE TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
PRESSURE YOU EXPECT TO ENCOUNTER
AND THE QUESTION IS WAS THIS ONE
TESTED TO THAT LEVEL AT ANY
POINT?
>> AND YOU KNOW THE COMPANY WILL
BE FACING THESE QUESTIONS AND
CONTINUE NOW GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> SARA?
>> JOINING US IS TITANIC EXPERT,
SCIENTIST AND UNDER SEA EXPLORER
AND A PHYSICIAN.
JOE McGINNIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU WERE PART OF THE FIRST
EXPEDITION TO LOCATE THE
WRECKAGE OF THE TITANIC, BUT YOU
HAD AN EXPERIENCE DOWN THERE
THAT MAY IN SOME WAYS RIVAL
THIS.
DID YOU ACTUALLY GET STUCK
WITHOUT COMMUNICATIONS FOR A
WHILE AND WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> WELL, ON MY SECOND DIVE TO
THE TITANIC.
I MADE ONE IN 1987 WITH THE
FRENCH GOVERNMENT RESEARCH SUB
AND THEN WITH THE RUSSIAN
RESEARCH SUB FROM RUSSIAN
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES IN 1991 AND
ON THAT DIVE WE MADE 17 DIVES TO
THE TITANIC.
I CO-LED THE EXPEDITION AND DID
THE SCIENCE AND ON THE LAST
DIVE, I CLIMBED INTO THE SUB
WITH THE CHIEF PILOT AND WE WENT
DOWN TO THE TITANIC AND LANDED
ON THE FLOOR OF THE PILOT HOUSE
AND SPENT SOME TIME REFLECTING
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE DONE AND WHAT
WE'D SEEN AND HAVING A MOMENT OF
RESPECT FOR THE OCEAN AND FOR
THE TITANIC ACCIDENT, AND AS WE
WERE ABOUT TO LEAVE THE PILOT
PUT ON THE THRUSTERS, OFF WE
WENT AND STOPPED ABOUT A METER
ABOVE THE FLOOR AND THEN HE PUT
IT BACK DOWN.
SO HE FOUND OUT VERY QUICKLY
THAT WE WERE STUCK, AND SO
WISELY, BECAUSE HE WAS AN
EXCELLENT PILOT, THEY CAME IN.
THE TWO PILOTS TALKED ABOUT WHAT
THE SITUATION WAS AND HE HAD PUT
OUR -- THE PILOT HAD SLID HIS
LEFT SIDE SKID UNDERNEATH THE
SUB.
WHEN HE LANDED THE SKID WENT
UNDER SOME TELEPHONE WIRE AND SO
WITH THE HELP OF THE SECOND SUB
AND CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
TWO WE MOVED UP AND DOWN AND
BACKWARDS AND WERE ABLE TO KIND
OF TIPTOE OUT OF THAT PRETTY
TENSE SITUATION, BUT AGAIN, IT
WAS GREAT COORDINATION, GREAT
PILOTS, GREAT SUBMARINES.
>> JUST THINKING ABOUT BEING IN
THAT SPACE FOR MOST OF US HUMANS
FEELS ANXIETY-PROVOKING, TO SAY
THE LEAST.
CAN YOU GIVE ME A SENSE OF WHAT
IT IS LIKE WHEN YOU'RE IN THAT
SCENARIO.
YOU ARE 12,000 FEET UNDER THE
PRESSURE OF THE WATER.
WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE?
WHAT IS THE SENSE OF BEING THERE
AND WHAT MIGHT THESE EXPLORERS
AND THESE FOLKS THAT WENT DOWN
THERE BUSINESSMEN, AS WELL, BE
FEELING RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, I CAN'T SAY.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE LIKE THE REST
OF US WHAT THEY'RE FEELING.
IT IS A VERY CONFINED SPACE, THE
SUBS THAT WE USE.
SO YOU GET USEDED TO THAT, BUT
FOR THESE FOLKS WHO ARE DOING
THIS FOR THE FIRST TIME IT MUST
BE RED LINE MOMENTS FOR THEM.
THE NEWS IS THAT P.H. IS WITH
THEM.
NARGEOLET IS ONE OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE TEAM AND YOU COULDN'T
HAVE A BETTER PERSON WITH YOU IN
A SITUATION LIKE THIS THAN P.H.
WHO HAS MADE 35 DIVES TO THE
TITANIC, WHO IS CALM UNDER
PRESSURE.
THE BEST KIND OF LEADERSHIP WILL
BE COMING FROM P.H.
HE WILL BE CALM, QUIET AND DOING
ALL OF THE RIGHT THINGS TO
CONSERVE ENERGY AND TO CONSERVE
OXYGEN AND TO CONSERVE
PSYCHOLOGICAL, EMOTIONAL ENERGY,
AS WELL.
>> BECAUSE THAT EXPENDS MORE
OXYGEN, AS WELL IF YOU START TO
HYPERVENTILATE OR START TO FREAK
OUT.
CAN YOU TALK TO ME ABOUT HOW
SIGNIFICANT THE SOUND THAT SONAR
HAS PICKED UP.
THERE HAS BEEN, EVERY HALF AN
HOUR FOR ABOUT FOUR HOURS A
BANGING SOUND IS HOW IT HAS BEEN
DESCRIBED.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
TRAINED TO DO TO MAKE SOUNDS SO
THAT SOMEONE MIGHT FIND YOU OR
DOES THAT TELL YOU THAT THIS IS
DEFINITELY HUMAN ACTIVITY OR
SOMETHING ELSE?
>> WELL, AS YOUR PREVIOUS GUEST
MENTIONED, IT'S AN INDICATION
POSSIBLY OF -- OF HUMAN ACTIVITY
THAT IS COORDINATED AND AGAIN,
THIS IS THE KIND OF THING THAT
WE WOULD HOPE -- WE'RE ALL
ENGAGED IN THIS KIND OF
COLLECTIVE IMAGINATION OF WHAT'S
GOING ON DOWN THERE AND WE ARE
BESET WITH FEAR AND SADNESS AND
HOPE AND -- AND UNCERTAINTY, BUT
THESE SOUNDS HAVE GIVEN US A
SENSE OF HOPE